this is Luigi and data pipelines high
data Chicago workshop if you're here for
that you were in the correct space you
want to go here about PI MC 3 room over
so feel free to settle in um so this is
a workshop I just wanted to let
everybody know we're gonna actually do
some mob programming and I will explain
what that is
midway through the talk and I'm not
gonna be talking for an hour and 15
minutes because I don't want to hear
myself talk for an hour and 15 minutes I
don't know if can imagine you guys do so
what's gonna happen in sort of the
structure is going to be I'm going to
introduce Luigi show you some basic
concepts we'll do a little bit of things
and then I'm going to set up a situation
and we're gonna think about sort of some
data analytics questions we'd like to
ask and then you guys are gonna work as
a group to we're gonna split up into
groups and you guys are gonna do a group
assignment it's gonna be fun but if you
are not in the mood to do group
assignment feel free just to listen to
the talk and you can wander over that
way
midway through I totally understand if
that's not your speed but I do there's
gonna be some audience participation
required so I want to give everybody a
heads up before I started so Luigi is a
data pipeline and batch processing tool
that was developed at Spotify
like 2011 2012 and has continually been
updated since then but before I talk
about how Luigi does things I wanted to
sort of bring in as part of my job as a
data scientist you need a data pipeline
which is that you if you're starting a
project it's gonna be hard to onboard
new people if you don't have clear
documentation how you go from your
source data whether that's production
data warehouse to online scraping to
what have you not you need some way to
organize your workflow edited rerun that
workflow and then collaborate so people
use lots of different tools to build
their data pipelines make is pretty
popular I'm sure you've all seen shell
scripts read Me's and documentation
who's who's gotten like a data project
where they've been assigned something
and they'll get like a readme on how to
download and clean the data and it
doesn't read me is not up to date and it
breaks that happens before yeah this is
why I sort of believe in the code over
configuration version of data pipelining
which is like don't document how you
build your data pipeline just have it be
able to run somewhere
Drake is another tool that's written in
Java there's all sorts of like AWS and
Google compute like data pipeline tools
that are entire that and then finally
Luigi which is entirely in Python and
we're at PI data and it makes things
nice for a lot of reasons and I'll
explain why
so Luigi is nice because it's entirely
in Python and it produces a graph of
dependencies for your data which is
there is basically these external
abstractions of tasks and targets that
produce a directed graph from your
source data to your final analysis
whether that be a model inputting data
and today yeah what have you not you
didn't define it but that graph it's
super easy to collaborate with because
you just send you can just run it on any
machine that has the dissonance ease
installed which is just Louie doing
whatever else you know and also it
scales well it with whether you're
running Hadoop jobs we're just running
Python scripts locally working with
Postgres or bigquery or what have you
not there's sort of wrappers around
working with those pretty common tasks
so I'm gonna go through like that's sort
of core abstractions at the heart of
Luigi and then we'll start playing
around with them so Luigi is sort of
built around this concept that like
everything is an atomic file operation
which I'll explain so you've probably
I've written stuff like this all the
time I have some code base and I
imported these functions generate
features fit model and deploy
predictions and I say you know if name
equals main run this maybe I'll set up a
cron job to run this nightly what
happens when fit model breaks or
generate deploy predictions break switch
things break it's just a fact of life
and you end up having yeah stuff breaks
and it breaks all the time yeah
it's in that there we go sorry yeah so
when something breaks fit model is not
defined I generated that error pretty
quickly but sometimes they're a little
bit more complex than that you'll want
to be able to resume at the broken step
so failures are gonna happen in both
your development and production
environments that's pretty much so by
reducing everything to like an atomic
operation on a file like a single unit
of work we're able to rerun from okay we
don't have the next step file but we
have the previous step so let's rerun
rerun only that rather than rerunning
from the start of the pipeline all over
again which especially as your data gets
larger or your calculations get more
complex it can be incredibly expensive
to like generate your features all over
again or you've been building out this
like dashboard data warehouse and now
that the data warehouse that supplies
your dashboard has had like generated
weekly reports for like 25 or 30 weeks
and it takes an hour to run each week
let's say what happens if you need to
rebuild each week so using the idea of
like this I atomic file or database step
allows you to us to resume from each
point so the way you'd sort of build
that in just pure Python like we have
these functions that I wrote again like
generate features fit model and deploy
predictions and I'll say okay if our
features don't exist generate the
features if the model does not exit
exist fit the model and if the
predictions date is not today deploy
these predictions because they're like
new predictions you want to update them
and deploy it into your production
environment so that's nice you can see
as the logic of a data pipeline gets
more complex from three arbitrary
functions that I didn't even write and
just made into like an actual like
complex graph of many different data
sources many different downstream
dependencies this becomes incredibly
hard to maintain so Luigi to make our
lives easy introduce the idea of
two different classes a task and a
target a task is an atomic atomic unit
of work it takes other tasks and targets
and produces other tart future targets
and a target is like a safe state of
data so a target is like a file that
would exist or rose in a database that
would exist what have you not so here's
our first task and I'm going to go
through each one of these lines pretty
slowly so we important Luigi and then
we're gonna subclass this Luigi dot past
thing to write our personal task so I
called it my past and it imports from
Luigi tasks we set up a parameter which
is so you can use these Luigi parameter
functions and that's basically so you
can get a simple command-line operation
and then lured so then we notice that it
requires some other tasks so this is
basically saying this task my task is a
downstream dependency of some other task
so if some other task has not been run
we cannot run my task so when we run
Luigi whether it's on the command line
or with the scheduler it's gonna run
some other tasks or make sure that it
has been run then run this is actually
where we execute Ord this is not playing
nice with me today this is actually this
is not freaked out on me here there so
run is actually what the task is doing
so in this in this case it's opening the
output of the prior task it's opening
its output which is this is given to you
by the self object in Luigi and this is
how you write out two files which is a
little bit weird compared to most Python
things so you open up this self that
output and that's whatever file it's
writing to for database is slightly
different we printed a hello world from
run and then
close the file and then finally we tell
Luigi we define our output which is
going to return a local target and then
it will save it to tempo bar bard such
so this will be whatever our parameter
is this is going to write to the
parameterize versions file so you can
imagine that's one way to keep track of
like which parameters you brand your
model for and which ones you haven't or
whatever your workflow is so we're gonna
actually let's go to the command line
and actually do this real quick so make
there can I make a scratch directory no
let's make a scratch directory and so
reports Luigi
so class might ask Luigi
that external task and the reason why
this is an external task rather than a
standard class is this is the first
there is no dependency of this it exists
as the first step so this is basically
defining that something has happened
outside the universe of this particular
pipeline that is sending up this one so
it will not well the example that we
provided how to requires a run and
output this is just gonna have a run and
an output so let's give it a parameter
and give it a defaults I'm gonna make
the defaults equal to 42 in the string
and then let's define the run method and
so in the run we want to output we want
to Brett grab the file of that we're
going to be outputting to so you call
self dot output and then you want to
open it and we're gonna open it in write
mode because we want to write and then
I'm gonna print to the file hello world
this is a Luigi job yeah you can
actually spell and then we're gonna
close the file and then finally we'll
define a local define the output which
is defining the target we're gonna want
to return a target that this is going to
be operating towards so return Luigi
local target it temp foo output dash dot
txt and make sure and we grab the
parameter all right so really simple
Luigi job right there
and so now actually let me exit this
because your guys aren't gonna be able
to see this so open up new thing we've
got our test stop you I so could do
Python test off um what do people think
is gonna happen when I run I thought and
test that py so it's gonna error because
you can't call a module object or did I
but anyways so you'll want to use the
Luigi command-line tool to invoke your
classes when you start so the module is
test and the task is my tasks and then
the pram is now like 23
no class test I'll see this is why I
miss write this let me check against
this I wrote this last night as well so
okay well here's the actual one this is
a little bit more interesting um why are
you okay Fran it's not working
got it so the parameter was not working
so I'm just gonna actually very quickly
delete this just to show that this will
actually print out to the file you can
get a sense of how you run a Luigi job
because there's a couple different ways
to run it and that's actually not
totally intuitive so we can run Luigi
test my task and we need to give it this
local scheduler flag because I will pull
this up so when we run it you notice
that I said you can run it either you
can either run Luigi jobs on both the
command line and using the Luigi Damian
daemon which has this nice graphical
interface I'll show both but when you're
working in testing environments you'll
want to use it running the command line
so I forgot to exceed at the module flag
so the module is the name of your Python
file generally the test so it's our
filename is test my task is the name of
the class I defined and I said use the
local scheduler have a module name TAS
okay
let's not remove it let's move it there
we go
why are you not liking them today
sadness also yeah might be I'm trying to
figure out why mm-hmm well there's
actually one way see I actually normally
so when I'm writing these I know we're
gonna fix this let's look at this so the
way I normally yeah yeah so I think this
should do it won't give me any quick
quick this is just a little quick
invocation I quickly do a lot of how I
normally write these because I always
forget to run a little we do command so
I just generally want to write Python uh
just as a force of habit and it forces
it onto using the system Python which
sometimes on AWS machines it gets kind
of nasty so now I should be able to go
locals
oh right
forget that register object is not huh
all right I'm gonna switch over to the
in the interest of getting us moving
over to the test that I pre wrote and
does in fact run spot in terms of money
running Luigi you can either run it
using the local scheduler option which
will run it locally on the command line
or you can run it using the Luigi daemon
so you only just start Luigi D
background and then run it as such so
you'll need to run Luigi D background to
start this so that you can run by
reading and the nice thing about okay
yeah it's already running that's why I
was if I go to localhost 8 or 8 - you
actually get this nice visualization of
all your possible running tests and
especially if you're like running this
on server and there's all sorts of ways
of configuring this to run like submit
jobs to like a master server that's
running your entire company's processes
and such so I think that's like
basically Luigi sorry that that didn't
like run right away I should have double
check that my dad but so what we're
gonna do for the rest of the session
with our remaining 45 minutes it's gonna
spend about 40 minutes 35 probably doing
a little bit of a mob programming
exercise we're going to think through
what sort of questions we want to ask of
our data pipeline and then we're gonna
split up into groups and build them so
if we go to data that city of Chicago
org you'll notice one of the first
things you'll see is building permits
it's number four today
and the city of Chicago has published
all these building permits so what we're
gonna do is as a large group we're gonna
figure out like five questions we're
gonna want to ask and then we're just
put into small groups so this is what
building permit data looks like and then
what you can see is I've written a Luigi
task
work and you might want some other words
they downloads this and writes it to a
permits file let's delete these no not
that one so we can see here is we go and
grab the permits data save it as a
response right into the output and then
save it as a local target called permit
CSV and
we run basic pipeline
I will pitch well
there yeah
sorry about this looking ugly but
that's fun stuff oh okay
well regardless let's pull this basic
pipeline so this basic this is this
basic external class that will give you
the data so I'll let you all copy this
but what I want to do now is maybe think
about what are a few types of questions
you'd want to ask of permits data if you
were say a data analyst for the city of
Chicago and you were making a report to
the City Council and we'll work on that
in insert mode see still continually
screwing up writing up commands on my
text editor so what are some questions
that you'd want to ask the dataset that
contains every building permit issued
from 2006 to today
what about yeah how many of each type of
permit any other questions which so the
city calls that contractor
so which contractors are getting permits
any other questions what's all it's like
you repeat that which the most expensive
permits location and probably want to
put that on a map right all right and
then let's get one more up here
so it's only from 2006 that are tracking
permits
what about we've got which contractors
are getting less permits
we've got location yeah
well which is if I was gonna say which
is if codes are the most well it's the
location would just tell you where they
are but like aggregating them into
groups which is a slightly different
than like plotting all their locations
so which ZIP codes have the most
development so I'm gonna leave these up
here and now we're gonna do so every so
who's here has done a mob programming
session before it's just like a new
concept to most people all right my
programming is pretty simple form like a
group of like five to ten of you and
somebody can pick up pick one laptop and
basically switch off whoever's
controlling the laptop and everybody can
talk every three or four minutes so if
everybody could form these groups
because we're gonna try and build a
pipeline that answers each of these
questions now that you've already
downloaded the data so if people who can
form groups that'd be great maybe your
row and you're also more than welcome if
you don't want to do like the
interactive stuff to go over to the PI
mc3 session that is also okay yeah oh
yeah sorry you can also just go to data
this is the download you are
I'm gonna copy this move this to the
bottom of course that doesn't fit
there's the whole URL in one screen